well next up most young children spend
their weekends playing in the park maybe
learning to ride a bike but the crawford
family has other ideas the family of
eight ran a marathon together at the
beginning of the month including their
six-year-old
rainier now unsurprisingly there's been
a bit of a backlash olympic marathon
runner lead troops and everything about
rainey running a marathon is completely
wrong
and the race director has now said that
only that runners aged 18 and over enter
and future which is the case for most
marathons so the bottom line is is six
years old too young to be running a
marathon really his dad ben crawford
doesn't think so and he joins me now mr
crawford thank you for joining me
hello pierce good to be here bit of a
delay so i'll keep my question short
why did you let your six-year-old join
you in the marathon and did you not have
any health concerns for him
we did have concerns except for this is
something we had been working through
for nine years we've run marathons as a
family with all of our other kids we
have six kids total and they've all
finished the marathon without any
complications or concerns
and about a year before this marathon he
watched his sisters run and at that
point he begged us to be a part of this
and we said well if you're willing to
train for it and as long as we run right
next to you and keep an eye on you the
entire way
we don't have any problem with you
participating in this activity because
we think it's good for you and we think
it's good for our family i mean i'm all
for a bit of tough love with kids you
know all my kids like sport i like to
push them as a parent to to be the best
of whatever they were doing but
certainly with my sons when they were
six i would never put them into a
marathon believing that their bodies
weren't big or strong enough to cope
with such a sort of physical ordeal and
a lot of the medical guidance as you
know recommends against it and thinks
that certainly boys and girls should get
through puberty
before they even consider this kind of
distance running uh but there are other
people who applaud you for being a tough
dad how have you felt about the the
criticism that's come your way
yeah well the first thing i probably
have an issue with is the way you phrase
it is put our child through this
you know we're pretty clear like we have
a culture of of a family where we've
done hard things but we've also
experienced the gratification that comes
from those hard things and our
six-year-old has observed that and he
chose this we didn't we didn't put it on
him we didn't i mean you could say we
gave him the idea because it's kind of
the culture of our family but we didn't
put him up to it
uh it was he he asked us and we allowed
it
uh so there's not a pressure coming from
that angle and on the research side
there isn't much at all in the medical
community there's like cautions you know
a lot of people say oh the risks may
increase but a lot of the studies are
very outdated that are being quoted and
the bottom line of what the medical
community community recommends now or
not recommends but says is that there is
no conclusion there's no evidence
uh you know they have their cautions
like they do with buying a stick of gum
or a pack of cigarettes
which maybe that's a bad example because
that's like blatantly bad for you but
for us bottom line is the benefits
health-wise and emotional that we've
seen with him and our family and our
other children is that the the benefits
far outweigh the potential risk that
we've heard about medically or in any
other way i mean it took him eight hours
36 minutes to finish it apparently he
was tearful at various stages of the run
how was he afterwards and in the few
days after the race
oh the day after he's jumping on or the
day of he's jumping on a trampoline he's
asking about doing a half marathon again
in a few days he's talking about doing
the marathon again next year uh eight
hours is pretty much a walking pace so
it's a fully active day it's a long
distance i've heard that disneyland says
the average kid walks seven miles in
disneyland without any training you know
there's no preparation for that so it's
a full day and it's a hard day but i
don't think it's quite what people are
making it out to be there's a there's
water every mile
uh there's we stopped for food and
drinks and playgrounds i think when
people see the video that we made about
it they'll see it's almost it's almost
ridiculous to even talk about a way
because of how fun it will appear that
we're having
i mean i am in two minds about this you
know i've watched the footage i've
listened to other interviews you've
given i've heard the criticism
every instinct with me is to support a
father pushing their kids
and i do think we've gone very soft as a
society i do think that and i do think
without there's such a premium now on
quitting and you know not putting
yourself through this kind of a physical
challenge if you like and then the other
part of me is a father it's like well
were my boys with that age would i have
made them run a marathon i'd have been i
would have been too scared to do that
worried that i might inflict some kind
of permanent damage so i'm sort of torn
do you understand that
oh i completely understand it but you
keep on using this language of push or
have my child do and to me that would be
a major red flag if we're pushing him
using our will to motivate him to enter
the race to continue the race and finish
the race i would expect massive backlash
from the community and from the child
but if the child wants to do it then i
think it's our job to assess like are
there major medical risks that the child
can't understand are there major
scientific risks if not then the
question is how can we support the child
to do it in the safest way possible
and then just be prepared to pull the
plug if we have to or if the child
changes their mind but never once in the
26 miles did he change his mind and say
that he wanted to quit the race
what next when he's seven is he off to
the triathlon what happens next
you know i i don't see it that way it's
not you know our family is not
competitive in that we're trying to do
the next hardest thing
uh we're asking the question right now
how can we make running fun for where
we're at now so next year it might be
something else that's fun and healthy
and challenging we've uh we've this is
not the first difficult thing we've done
our family kind of like got some media
attention for in 2018 when we hiked the
2000 mile appalachian trail so our kids
have a road map for at least knowing
what's possible for them i don't care if
they run uh for the rest of their life
or become competitive like they don't
time themselves we're not pushing them
but i want them to know that it's at
least an option
and that it's possible and it's
something they can do if they choose to
ben crawford fascinating conversation i
actually think i've come around to your
way of thinking
i do actually i didn't think i would in
that three minutes really i think you've
been quite persuadable actually yeah
because in the end you know your child
better than anybody else if he genuinely
was on a trampoline after the race
clearly no real harm was done
you know what who's to say that a
six-year-old if they want to do it can't
do that
so a great conversation thank you very
much indeed
thank you